[Music]
[Music]
hey guys it's justine and welcome to my
apple watch series 6 review i've been
absolutely loving this of course
i absolutely love my apple watch so this
is no exception to be completely honest
with you the apple watch series 6 is not
a huge upgrade you already do have a
series 5 watch
this maybe isn't the watch for you but
if you do have something that is lower
than a 4 or
3 this will be a huge upgrade they also
now have an apple watch sc which is a
lower cost and they do
still have the apple watch series 3 as
well so there are a bunch of price range
options for the apple watch
and i cannot stress enough how much i
love this thing i've had almost every
generation
since the apple watch was first
introduced and over the past
three years there was a point where i
really
needed to start taking my health
seriously i wasn't working out i really
was doing
basically nothing i mean i was honestly
doing the bare minimum
to survive i know a lot of you guys have
probably seen a lot of the stories of
how the apple watch has helped save
people's lives
and i think what is important is yes the
apple watch is a catalyst for that
but knowing what your normal is like
what is your blood pressure what is your
normal heart rate
the fact that now you can take your o2
levels and be able to test your blood
oxygen
is really really crucial and this is
something that i've really
never paid attention to in the past
these are all very important things
and the fact that you can have that all
right here on your wrist is
so amazing
[Music]
the apple watch and fitness basically
goes hand in hand and i know i've talked
about this so much but the apple watch
has really
really helped me kind of quantify my
fitness and up until recently i never
actually went in and looked at the data
and i could see
a significant increase in my fitness and
also a significant
decrease in my fitness when i stopped
working out as much i have
five or six years of heart rate data
that i can go back and track these
trends and be able to have that if i
ever need to give that to a doctor or
anything of the sort the o2 sensor in
this is just another added benefit of
being able to quantify and track your
health
it also runs in the background so it'll
periodically be able to give you updates
and i've actually been wearing this for
the past few days
while i slept uh this is gonna be my
first night of sleep tracking with the
new apple watch
series six it's 12 30 right now a.m
and i have to get up at 5 30 to post a
video at 6 a.m so
this first night of sleep tracking is
gonna be quite interesting
this is also gonna be my first time
sleeping with the new braided watch and
now siri thinks that
i'm trying to talk to her because i
raised to no cancel
the real question is what is my battery
percentage right now
the battery percentage is 51
so when i wake up i'm gonna charge it
i think and then at some point i'm gonna
work out
and then at some point i don't i don't
know stay tuned
well wrong way night night
so i woke up at like 5 25. i actually
woke up before my alarm
so it's asking me if i want to turn it
off i'm finally going to get out of bed
i went to bed
my watch was 51 it's now 41
i'm gonna get up post my video and then
go back to bed
okay i'm going back to bed it is
um 6 18 video was posted
and now i'm gonna sleep until
not sure maybe like 9 30 maybe 10
i don't know it's gonna be a surprise to
me and you
night night i gotta set my bedtime again
i'm up it's 9 19. i gotta charge this
thing so my battery's at 31
last night i went to bed it was 51 so
this is our current situation we're at
31
and now we're gonna charge it while i go
eat some breakfast and then
i don't know carry on with my day so
i've tracked the last one
two three four nights of sleep this one
is not good
i went to sleep at 12 39 and i woke up
at 5
24 am that was the day that i was
posting my apple watch video at 6am and
i was
trying to finish editing it the night
before i'm a very deep sleeper
not much wakes me up at all it's kind of
cool to be able to really
see this data right here real time so
since i do normally wake up at 6am
i'm gonna set this time for
i would have to go to bed at least by 10
to get eight hours so i'm gonna say i
want to be in bed by 9 30.
i'm so old
here's some blood oxygen tracking here's
some data this is kind of cool because i
can see
when i sort of had a lower range which
seems to be
when i'm sleeping so this is the vo2 max
data
and this is what's kind of fascinating
because i hadn't looked at this until
recently so let's see we're going to go
back to march
2018 which was two years ago the fact
that i have all of this data dating back
two years ago is so cool vo2 max is the
maximum amount of oxygen your body can
consume during exercise so you basically
want to have a higher vo2 max
this indicates a higher level of cardio
fitness and endurance
so march 2018 not so good may
2018 i started working out again 44.6
and you can see the trend slowly goes
down here
from july to october back to 39.
struggle city august 2019
to december nothing too crazy but then
sort of when the pandemic hit
all the fitness activities that i used
to do i couldn't do any longer
thankfully i was quarantined with a
treadmill so
you can really see the increase here
from february
to june so we went from 39.1 to
44.4 and then i was slacking a little
bit
and then recently i started running a
lot more so currently we're at 45.3
i'm about to do my first run with the
apple watch
i um i also haven't charged it yet
so i just woke up i woke up like a long
time ago but
my plan is i'm gonna run hopefully the
battery will stay charged
we're at 15 percent
i hope that'll be okay i should have
charged it before the workout while i
was doing
actual work my computer but i didn't so
anyway time
to do the run hopefully it'll last first
run with the new apple
also good news six percent battery so i
did make it through the run
and that's exciting
[Music]
so this is really cool to be able to
actually
see a difference and you know i think
when you first start working out you'll
start to feel differently but to be able
to have these numbers right in front of
you to actually validate all of the work
that you're putting into it
is pretty awesome another thing that i
was also doing was tracking my foods and
i was tracking them very specifically
because i was trying to link
what foods actually made me feel better
this was also a question that i got on
twitter because i was talking about how
i can't track a lot of the training that
i do
so in jiu jitsu the last thing that you
should be doing is
wearing an apple watch you can hurt your
training partner you can hurt yourself
you could also break the watch and this
is
not something that you should ever wear
you shouldn't wear jewelry you shouldn't
wear anything so i was wondering
this does have a martial arts tracking
on it so i got a question on twitter
asking if i trained with my apple watch
when i do jiu-jitsu and the answer is
absolutely not you can hurt yourself you
can hurt your training partner
like that's the last thing that you
should do but there is a martial arts
workout on here so i feel like you could
maybe use that if you're doing solo
drills
or if you have this
wouldn't recommend that either because
you're still going to probably hurt
yourself
this was also a really bad quarantine
purchase but
why don't you tell us what this is oh
yeah this is my training dummy
one of the biggest questions that i've
got when you guys see pictures of my gym
you're like what is that creepy thing in
the corner
this is uh this is a training dummy and
you know what
i thought this was going to be a really
great idea that i could use this to
train since
you know quarantine you can't train with
a person i don't like it and you guys
probably don't either
so like it is okay if you're doing solo
drills which i guess
i was kind of using it for mostly just
to do like
okay you know
some circling thing but like it's like
it's not real this is not a real body
like how am i gonna try to pass your
guard like this i just can't
it's it's fine this thing also scares me
in the middle of the night because it's
just sitting out here and if i have to
walk out here to go to the bathroom i
think it's a person
i'll tell you one thing if you guys ever
need to move a body
[Music]
we're a couple days into testing the
apple watch series six and my apple
watch actually doesn't know how to
respond to that
this is the graphite stainless steel
case with the milanese
graphite loop and this has actually
already been unboxed by my sister but i
really wanted to show you guys how cool
this looks because it is
a beautiful beautiful watch if you've
already seen the unboxing of my sisters
well welcome to number two
this looks really good very shiny
she did a very good job packaging this
back up i will say that
here's the thing i love the solo loop so
much
that i feel like i'll probably never
even wear this this would be like my
fancy going out red carpet look
but i don't see myself ever
doing that ever again what's cool now is
you can pair
multiple apple watches in ios 14 so it's
really nice because if i do want to
switch up i can
just continue using both of these and
then pair them
as needed but yeah look at you oh you're
upside down because you don't know me
yet
so over the past couple of days i have
been sleeping with this every single
night and it's
been kind of interesting trying to
figure out when i should charge it so
usually i will wake up then i will
charge it as soon as i get up i will
either
eat breakfast or do some email and then
it's ready to go
and then i'll start working out with it
and then i'll just continue on my day
but the one thing that has been really
cool
is it will give you an alert on your
iphone when
your apple watch is fully charged
[Music]
the coolest thing is the new bike
directions in ios 14
and paired with the apple watch it was
amazing i took the whole way here i was
able to just look at my watch to get my
directions
and i even tracked my bike ride 5.27
miles
50 minutes we're still going
it is so nice outside i love it
[Music]
here we go outdoor cycle hour 26 minutes
10.2 miles
average speed 7.1 i think we have to
kind of split these in half because
uh the calories of of this ride because
my bike is
sort of pedal assist but i'm really
hungry and tired from all of my
workouts today for you guys for this
review like my legs were
those are my legs so it's been about two
weeks with the apple watch and obviously
it's no surprise you guys know i'm such
a huge fan of the apple watch and this
one of course
is no exception so what have i been
doing for the past couple of weeks well
i've been challenging some of my friends
to some fitness activities
and that's one of my most favorite
things being able to really see what my
friends are up to
and have that kind of friendly
competition to go that extra few steps
to close your rings and i have to say
that marquez has beat me yet again
and most of the time it's because i have
not closed my stand goal
and that makes me really sad i've been
spending a lot of time editing
the best part about it is now i've
actually been using this to track my
sleep my favorite part though about the
sleep tracking
is the gentle haptic feedback that i get
in the morning when my alarm goes off
and i almost feel like the past couple
of weeks i have been waking up
feeling much more refreshed because you
don't wake up with this crazy loud alarm
just blaring
it's just like a gentle tap on your
wrist
i wake up i like i hit snooze for a
second
and then i go back to sleep for a few
seconds and then it's like
hey you're still sleeping and that's
when i get up i think if you do have an
apple watch older than the series 5 or
the series 4 that's where you're going
to really see the difference you also
see a difference with the charging
all in all i think the most important
thing is being able to have these heart
tracking features just to be able to get
that consistent baseline of what is your
heart rate i think that's really one of
the most important things
if you guys have any other questions
about this apple watch or anything in
general feel free to leave those in the
comments below
i look forward to doing a follow-up
video answering any of your questions
and talking more about my love for the
apple watch
maybe i'll come back and be so just
strong that i will just pick up this
table and
throw it you'll be like wow she's strong
she works out with the other ones
that'll be when apple fitness comes out
look out
[Music]
you